nous recevons à présent une pme de
guyancourt un qui a déjà conquis la
france avec ses jeux de société et qui
part à l'assaut de la chine nicolas
benoit bonsoir soit vous êtes
responsable marketing chez asmodée
france donc c'est le nom de cette pme
votre produit phare c'est le jungle
speed je sais pas si vous connaissez
en mai la liste vous avez l'air bien
c'est très amusant voilà il 120 350
mille par an c'est dire le succès alors
comment comment est ce que vous faites
parce qu'avec le numérique le succès des
jeux vidéo vous arrivez à vendre et à
grossir pour une pme avec des jeux
toujours plus créatif vous en éditer une
vingtaine par an plus une vingtaine mais
par rapport aux jeux vidéo le jeu de
société n'est pas en régression le jeu
vidéo est un marché complètement à part
c'est pas un concurrent c'est pas un
concurrent on n'est pas sur les mêmes
sur le même segment d'achat on pense
soit le même prix d'achat ce jeu vidéo
demeure assez cher pour une durée de vie
qui est assez courte
il ya une concurrence féroce il ya les
achats dématérialiser la piraterie les
copies enfin toutes ces choses tous ces
problèmes que nous ne connaissons pas
qu'on peut pas faire à terrebonne saint
louis et donc nous en fait le jeu de
société c'est quelque chose qui est qui
perdure les ça permet de rassembler la
famille autour de jeux éducatifs drôle
qui qui donne une grande convivialité à
l'intérieur de la cellule familiale
donc c'est quelque chose qui perdure et
qui est une tradition de continuer le
marché de jeux de société et ne crois
pas ni ne baisse pas depuis des années
on rassure des niveaux qui sont
constants assez élevé vous avez réussi à
faire grimper votre chiffre d'affaires
assez rapidement les chiffres donc que
j'ai en quatre ans de 25 millions à 100
millions d'euros aujourd'hui
alors 100 millions c'est le groupe mais
voilà parce qu'on a on a maintenant six
filiales à l'étranger donc donc 100
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
pour l'ensemble du groupe dont 50
millions réalisés à l'étranger à travers
nos six filiales alors comment est ce
que vous trouvez toutes ces idées ou
est-ce qu'on soit un jeu alors on a
aussi cessé la part importante de
travail parce que c'est là la recherche
et développement qu'on pourrait
retrouver dans d'autres types
d'industries on a des gens qui sont
spécialisées dans la conception de jeux
et on travaille un petit peu comme des
éditeurs de livres
on a reçoit des manuscrits qui sont
faites les prototypes de jeux qu'on
essaye conteste dont une partie
importante de travail consiste à jouer à
tester des jeux donc c'est pas
désagréable et dont on teste ses jeux on
les développe on les sélectionne et on
les met sur le marché donc c'est les
jeux nous éditons sont vraiment des
productions
maison parce que parfois vous êtes
trompé ça arrive oui bien sûr oui bah on
est dit entre 20 et 30 jeux par an donc
forcément il ya forcément des jeux qui
auquel on a cru qu'ils nous ont plu mais
qui n'ont pas rencontré leur public
qu'ils ont toujours pas fonctionné ça
peut arriver et de l'idéal à la création
puis à la vente
où est ce que son produit les jeux alors
les la matière grise qui produit les
jeux c'est ici à guyancourt un fin de
nos bureaux sont à guyancourt donc on
travaille en liaison aussi avec nos
filiales pour le développement pour
qu'ils cadrent les produits par rapport
à leur marché et après la fabrication
physique l'impression la cendre
l'assemblage se fait soit en allemagne
qui est un grand pays de production de
jeu parce qu'ils ont ils ont une grosse
tradition d'impression de jeux de
société un gros marché et éventuellement
en chine pour les jeux qui comporte des
pièces en plastique mais on est en train
de tendre à ramener ce type de
production en europe parce que
la production chinoise présente aussi
des inconvénients de délais de fiabilité
et de qualité qui peut parfois être
pas forcément au rendez vous et c'est
aussi une volonté de favoriser le made
in app reste une entreprise donc la
volonté cette facilité la qualité du
produit parce que c'est notre cheval de
bataille il faut que nos produits soient
de qualité donc la qualité des produits
la rentabilité ça va de soi et si
effectivement et l'europe c'est plus
près c'est plus simple en terme de
logistique en termes de coût en termes
de gestion de la fabrication aller sur
place pour voir comment se déroule voilà
c'est beaucoup plus simple que la chine
veut pas dire qu'on fabrique urbaine en
chine un enfant continue il ya des
choses qu'on ne pourra pas rapatrier en
europe mais on tend à voir cette volonté
là quelques images de vos jeux de
société oui je veux servir à l'entretien
alice vous avez testé lesquels et je
voudrais tester le doble ou acquis notre
eau notre grand succès depuis deux ans
un jeu qui s'est vendu à 450 milles
exemplaires c'est le jeu de société plus
vendu en france
time's up aussi qui est un gros gros
succès alors les sprints épisode qui a
battu karité de se situer sur un segment
où on imagine traditionnellement jeux de
société pour les enfants
time's up stand up c'est un jeu pour les
jeunes adultes
kiki ben voilà ok ou de passer une
soirée rien faire jouer à des jeux de
société dont time's up et quantité
d'autres qu'on ait dit non qu'il ya un
vrai un vrai vecteur de croissance
danser danser dans ce segment là et ça
occupe bien l'espace dali seront là bien
c'est ça les a jamais alors nous
verrions justement du lieu de
fabrication de vos jeux et nous avons
demandé aux saint quentinois s'il était
sensible au lieu de fabrication des
jouets qu'ils achètent on regarde la
réponse est donc vous avez 25
oui parce que je préfère les jouets en
bois fait bien de chez nous dans le jura
que les jouets made in china
comme j'ai deux petits en bas âge on
fait attention non jamais je fais jamais
ça justement s'avérer très courts
devraient faire oui parce qu'il ya
certaines s'étaient joints que je
voudrais pas acheter je ne serai pas sûr
que ce soit solide que ce soit conforme
parce que je veux pas mes petits-enfants
oui tout à fait c'est important pour
vérifier qu'il n'y ait pas de risque
pour les petits hauts niveaux aussi bien
des produits que si jamais ils mettent
les objets à leur bouche pas si c'est
vraiment le jouer que je veux qu'ils
n'existent que dans un seul type série
j'ai tendance à ne pas regarder et je
préfère les jouets fabriqués en france
ou en europe plutôt que des jouets
on sait qu'ils sont fabriqués dans des
mauvaises conditions alors nicolas beney
on a l'impression que c'est plutôt
important pour les gens la provenance
des jouets est ce que si vous rapatriez
tout votre production en europe ça peut
être aussi un moyen de communication est
ce que vous allez peut-être pas disons
que c'est un peu dans l'air du temps
forcément oui ça peut mais ça peut
l'être mais enfin j'entends des gens qui
ce qu'ils avaient peur sur la qualité
enfin il ya des normes en or après on
fait pas n'importe quoi n'importe pas
n'importe quoi donc le marché du jouet
et du jeu est très encadrée on peut pas
mettre fin les gens soient rassurés et
demi au commerce
voilà ce qu'elle vend demi nue dans le
commerce on enterre marché dans les
grandes surfaces spécialisées tous et
toutes ces choses sont contrôlés il n'y
a pas de sap avec des choses qui passent
très mal du film et en général les
fabricants font très attention donc il
n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir sur sa
face à l'inquiétude à voir c'est pour
les emplois en france
ça c'est un autre débat mais c'est vrai
que les fabricants français il ya très
peu de choses qui sont fabriqués en
france il ya quelques quelques jouets en
bois effectivement c'est une tradition
injure à un peuple un peu d'injection
plastique aussi mais ça reste très sinon
la grande majorité des choses sont
fabriqués en chine
nous nos particularités que nos jeux de
société sont beaucoup imprimé en
belgique en allemagne parce que on a des
fabricants qui ont cette tradition
laïque qui savent le faire vraiment bien
alors à ce mode est incessant 70
employés dans le monde dont 70 en france
en vous disais c'est voilà vous êtes en
train de vous développer à
l'international en 2011 vous avez vendu
près de 6 millions de jeux dans le monde
et maintenant vous partez en chine
un petit pas alors comment est ce que
vous envisagez cette implantation parce
que culturellement c'est quand même
assez différent il faut adapter ces jeux
de société va pas forcément le
bon la chine est un grand pays où
débitant une classe moyenne émergente
importante qui commence fin qui a le
pouvoir d'achat d'acheter des produits
occidentaux entre guillemets nous on y
va tout doucement parce que justement ça
un grand pays qu'on va apprendre à
connaître et on sait que c'est un peuple
de gens qui aiment le jeu ils ont
inventé le mah jong il aime les jeux de
société s'est avéré enfin donc on a
envie de leur proposer nos jeux de
société qui ont fait leurs preuves en
france et dans d'autres pays
et puis l'avantagé vous avez des jeux où
il n'y a pas forcément besoin enfin
c'est qu'ils sont universels on peut
jouer avec des actes manger quels sont
les dix dobbels ont des jeux universel
on peut jouer mais déjà gospic
typiquement c'est un jeu effectivement
qu'on peut jouer avec des gens dont on
parle pas la langue et d'expliquer un
petit peu la règle et ça ça fonctionne
ces jeunes veulent c'est pareil c'est
des symboles c'est tout le monde se
comprend et du rire de la bonne de la
bonne humeur
donc ces gens là sont on va les proposer
au marché chinois sous le même nom bon
après on est en tout n'est pas encore
définie mais effectivement il ya des
adaptations culturelles qui seront
nécessaires au niveau du packaging des
noms de la communication évidemment donc
c'est pour ça qu'on y va doucement pour
apprendre pour découvrir le pays
et on a de grandes espérances sur la
chine mais en gagnant modestement
travail
on poursuit la chronique de l'écho à
l'histoire est en retard ce soir mais on
va quand même passer aux infos en plus
il a recommencé une information qui est
un petit peu moins réjouissante ce sont
les magasins game qui sont au bord de la
faillite alors aurait-il voilà vous
disiez 1 victime de piraterie etc
aurait-il trouvé repreneur lancer une
distribution de jeux vidéo avait été
placé en redressement judiciaire en
automne dernier
aujourd'hui 40 des 160 boutiques en
france pourrait être reprise par son
concurrent micromania pour un montant de
1 million d'euros
game emploie actuellement 900 personnes
en france en 2011 la filiale française a
publié une perte nette de 3 7 millions
d'euros pour un chiffre d'affaires de
196 millions d'euros alors dans les
yvelines la société britannique compte
sept magasins dont un à skywest en tout
prédit sied à montigny en pleine période
de soldes les articles ont été bradées
un magasin a été complètement dévalisés
aujourd'hui il est fermé donc celui
voilà on y est indiqué sur la vitrine
que la boutique fermera au plus tard le
19 janvier nous voilà le triplement des
sommes devancé devancé l'appel puisque
de toute façon magasin est quasiment
vide
exact que rien avancer comme ça à
travers toute la france l'autre en vous
en plus ce soir ça concerne la ville
d'elancourt
oui alors la ville et l'encours s'est
classée parmi les trois villes les mieux
gérées et responsable des yvelines eh
oui selon l'association contribuables
associés à l'heure en 2006 déjà
elancourt avait été distingué par le
magazine challenge à l'agenda du sort à
présent très rapidement très rapidement
je fais vite de rendez vous à la cité
des métiers
mardi 22 janvier un atelier pour
utiliser au mieux vos smartphones et
tablettes dans votre vie professionnelle
et puis une réunion d'information sur
les métiers de l'architecturé mercredi
23 janvier de 14h30 à 16h30 tous ces
rendez vous sont gratuits à la cité des
métiers cet attrape et puis cette
exposition tous en coopératif c'est
jusqu'au 31 janvier à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux
si vous voulez découvrir un autre moyen
de faire du commerce en autres moyens
d'entreprendre
alice c'est votre dernière chronique et
fried
merci mais dont la rédaction mais ne
vous savez pas vous imaginez bien qu'on
n'allait pas vous laisser partir comme
ça si je précise tout de même que c'est
votre dernière chronique rico pour des
raisons professionnelles puisque vous
allez poursuivre cette carrière de
journaliste ailleurs après passé donc
porter défilent depuis un an et demi et
c'est pas tous les jours facile on va le
voir petit montage préparé par romain
respini ah oui
c'est du café avec une pointe de whisky
fort dès le matin des bombes soient pas
avant de se quitter on jette un coup
d'oeil à l'agenda pour la partie
décryptage avec alice bonsoir à l'issue
est sérieux ces dernières semaines on a
l'impression qu'il manquait un petit
rongeur fond de lancement prévue par
action
qu'attend qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je
dise en fait lorsque tu perds c'est
l'anti feria déjà ça marche aux deux
peuples est en tout cas existent depuis
le 1er juin des nourrices ont sauvé ce
que par contre c'est de 10h à 11h30 30
remp et qu'est ce que j'ai l'habitude de
traiter ça nous sommes libres
non on première et dernière fois je
m'excuse auprès de tous les marseillais
vraiment je suis désolé ce film ma
famille ma femme et mon frère sur son
confrère et voilà fait porter un maillot
de l'ol endroit là même que vous êtes de
mars et c'est pour ça c'était difficile
mais on avait réussi à vous faire porter
ce maillot de paris merci à lisbonne le
sourire sur le plateau ne pleurez pas je
les kano nord merci à grimacer notre
victoire
alice que cette fuite qui se poursuit ce
soir un peu de culture les moutons ou
amoureux en islande
si j'ai bien suivi le conducteur je
crois qu'on va parler de ça tout de
suite des danseuses moutons des enfants
spectateurs et acteurs des coeurs de
laine et de lumière qui ndour c'est
avant tout un spectacle conceptuel
tout part d image et
c'est tout à fait ça comme une
scénographie et ben nous on danse avec
les images en fait pour les faire parler
c'est un voyage à travers les saisons
des l'islande et à travers aussi le
l'imagination de ses moutons
comment il voit là les quatre saisons
notre directeur artistique qui a fait un
voyage en islande
il est tombé amoureux de tous les
paysages et
toutou qui fait tout ce qui fait partie
en fait des de l'islande
il a vu que les moutons sont très
importants et amusant aussi
au début du spectacle chaque enfant du
public reçoit un petit coeur en laine
qui permettra de communiquer avec les
artistes sur scène lorsque le coeur
s'allument les enfants savent qu'ils
doivent remonter sur scène
il en découle une connexion un jeu entre
et des danseuses chalet
à jouer je suis allé je suivis à miers
qui viennent ému quand y'a les
explosions j'ai bien aimé sa vie
d'enfant ça t'a plu ce spectacle oui
qu'est-ce que tu as aimé
quant au bébé après cette première
représentation prisme à elancourt la
compagnie du tp au se produira les
vendredi 18 et samedi 19 janvier à
l'estaminet de magny les hameaux